AND HERE WE ARE FROM DOWN HE SCC
ON MURRAY.
DEEP INTO THE CORNER.
OFF THE WALL AND FEED MURRAY.
WATCH
PASS.
BROUGHT IN ON THE
GETTING IT WITH THEM ALL.
TRYING TO
MILLER BY TWOTIME.
BACK TO THE POINT.
AND BROKEN UP NOW.
AND MURRAY LOST THOSE GUYS IN E
UNIFORMS HEADING IN HIS
BACK TO THE RIVER TOFRONT.
AND HERE'S OLSON HERE.
HE WAS NOT ABLE TO GET THAT
SETTLED DOWN. HARD HIT IN THE
SCORED!
SLAMMED HOME BY CODY  BACK
ACROSS THE GREEN. THE PUCK BACK
CHIAROT.
WHATET
FRESH LEGS OUT.
THE SABRESS
BACK IN.
IT IN ON
PERIOD NUMBER THREE.
CANADIENS, TWO-ON-ONE.
RIGHT OS CAUGHT THERE.
THE TW WIDEMAN.
UP THE MIDDLE.
AND MONTREAL STARTING BACK.
IN OVER THE BUFFALO LINE HELD H
THOMPSON SAYS YOU CAN KNOCK ME
SMOTHER IT.
>> Rob: EXCELLENT JOB THERE BY
DYLAN COZENS. FROM
MONTREAL ONLY LAST EXCHANGE.
HE GOT DONE TALKING
ABOUT JEFF
TEAMMATES DO.